but you know about did i tell you about
the bonding when nick jonas threw a
pineapple on my face
it's a weird [ __ ] sentence but go
ahead nikki
i was in vietnam
[Music]
hello everybody welcome back to big mood
we got an outstanding cast for you today
an outstanding lineup of people if i do
say so myself we have our special guest
in the house jess lazama she is here she
is ready to share her world views her
life her opinions and her energy oh my
goodness
i told you she was special
we also have gina darling in the house
you might have seen her on g4 tv
you might have seen her attack of the
show invite to party being a freaking
nerd playing dungeons and dragons
and me i'm not playing poker right now
so i'm here
go
um today we are talking about a topic
that
i found very interesting seeing as it
was sent from one of our other group
members who was younger than uh than i
and jess maybe i'm offended i don't know
how old you are i don't know 32. um okay
yeah maybe she was i think she's younger
she's one of our other ones she is a
mother of two and she is a wife of our
producer but she sent us this article to
go over and um react to and it is um
things that older people
old people
uh should tell young people dun dun dun
dun i can't wait to learn from these old
folks yeah i'm ready to share my videos
when do the old people step in and talk
about it
i'm ready to learn
um these are supposedly quote unquote
taboo things that maybe that's why
they're not talked about so much and i
thought that was interesting because
there's so much that i wish i would have
known um you could listen to podcasts
like [ __ ] they don't tell you uh for for
other things that maybe
true they should have told you they
couldn't tell you um it's a podcast that
i've heard of color
but um yeah i haven't read through the
this list yet because i did want to get
our honest reactions to them and see if
you've experienced any of these if we
could shed light on uh any of these
subjects for the youths okay i feel like
i'm going to be the old one here
but you don't look at it no it's younger
than all of us
wild
i lived a lot of life though
you're the youngest here yeah like nine
lives in this lifetime it's amazing as
you do i feel like you have so much to
contribute life experience wise to the
world without
looking like it and that's the goal yeah
that's always the goal truly it's an
illusion so we'll get started here and
see if we have any wisdom to impart
uh
one in a workplace don't be afraid to
talk with co-workers about pay companies
make it taboo because it increases the
chances of having to give raises yeah
and you can't get fired for that
absolutely not you can't get fired and
it's not illegal to talk about pay yeah
yeah you know
i mean i guess it's hard because i've
never really worked a nine-to-five job
but in the influencer world because it
was such a new thing i feel like people
were getting severely underpaid
and you don't know about it until you
talk to someone else about what their
rate is and it is so taboo i don't know
why it is why is that yeah because it
all comes down to like what are you
what's it worth right yeah and i think
we should that should be an open thing
because it at the time when it just
begun we never knew it was unchartered
no so we were like we don't know we're
getting paid
yeah
a thousand we're
and you don't recognize the value that
actually they usually spend hundreds of
thousands on their marketing and like
you have access to
eyeballs that they would have had to pay
for a lot more for and then you start
talking you're like oh [ __ ] it does make
sense actually
but i think that
people don't share because maybe they're
like
either prideful or they're like they
don't want you to know how much money
they make or maybe they don't want you
to take their derb or something but i
think it's it would be the opposite like
it should be the opposite because you
don't want someone to take
such a low pay for doing the same job as
you you'll be priced out of your job and
it also like reduces the value as well
yeah
it undermines the value of the entire
scope of work that all of you do i
really appreciate it um that
tim he's so open about everything that
he gets paid for because so like if he
had a brand deal with this brand and
they reach out to me i'll just hit up to
be like yo how much they pay you yeah
they'll tell me straight up like thanks
man so i really appreciate people like
that he'll give you a real honest truth
because we share the same tax team and
before i decided to work with them
because my dad was an accountant so i
was like switching over from family to
like um to their team they're like you
know we represent oh and they gave me a
whole list of youtubers that i know and
one of them was tim and
tim was having his aunt do his taxes
before he was a cpa and he switched over
i was like huh okay it's a similar
situation why did he decide to switch so
i hit him up and i was like hey uh is it
worth it do you like it are you happy i
knew he would give me a right answer
like a honest answer and he's like
seriously yeah i put them to the test i
had them talk to my cpa who was actually
my aunt who is my cpa but like they
didn't know we were related and she gave
me she like vetted them
and that's great and she was like yeah
they're legit like it's worth it i'll
neither number later send it off yeah i
definitely will this is an advertisement
for them
but yeah it's really helpful to have
people willing to talk to you in your
little in your inner circle of
colleagues because how would you know
yeah otherwise you don't know what like
what's the parameters yeah you're not
given that you just think that what
you're getting is is a sweet deal and
then you don't have negotiation tactics
like and you always want to negotiate
you want some sort of leverage or
something that you can bring to the
table to know like at least a ballpark
of what you
should be getting paid right i think the
only thing that would be like concerning
it's like if i go to you nikki and i'm
like oh how much are you getting paid
while we're working here at macy's or
something and you're like oh i'm getting
paid this and then i go to the boss and
be like well nikki told me that you were
paying her this like will that get nikki
in trouble i don't think so because why
wouldn't i be able to share that with
like that's like my own personal
information to share yeah so like it's
like if you asked me like you know what
do you have any cancerous moles and i'm
like yeah actually i do you know like
why would it for me it's like i wouldn't
want the boss to start treating you
terribly right that that could happen
yeah because that's not illegal they
can't fire me exactly but they could
treat you mean to your co-worker
different and that's why if you do ask i
don't think you should rat anybody out i
think you just say hey i heard from
others that this is seems to be the
going rate right yeah don't throw them
under the bus and say schmicky shmimo
yeah or just ask for a raise knowing
that like everyone else is compensated
higher than you and like you they
probably will give you a raise if you're
doing a good job and if not ask them why
you aren't eligible for a raise and what
you can do to get a raise you definitely
don't know until you ask yeah asking
questions is so important and i think
that's the other thing it's like people
don't know that they can ask yeah that
they're not going to get fired for
asking right you should never feel like
your job is on the line for asking
questions yes and also negotiating
things no never take the first offer
yeah or um
whatever your rate is it's like you know
it's going to be a negotiation so you
start higher they're going to start
lower and then you guys meet them and
then you meet where you wanted it to be
anyway with anything too like with
buying a car
don't [ __ ] go for the first price
they tell you you can always negotiate
that i made them sit there until
midnight once it really is the best and
they're like we just want to go home
girl i know you do yeah i got [ __ ] to do
you know what i loved about buying a car
is that i did all the research i love
[ __ ] researching everything and i'm
like okay i'm gonna get this price for
it
and um and my i brought my dad with me
because i just don't you know as a woman
i didn't want to go by myself and steve
wasn't there because i was in santa
barbara and um
he goes with me and i'm negotiating
everything but they keep talking to him
and they keep trying to like talk him
like hey this is all we can do is that
okay and she's he's like don't talk to
me that's her and i'm being the hard ass
and they're like ah [ __ ] yeah not her we
don't want to deal with her okay let me
go talk to my manager again
like kelly blue book says that i deserve
blah blah blah for my trading vehicle
it's good to know you should have that
sort of
that confidence it's like it's all about
the confidence you have in the leverage
that you're bringing absolutely okay
number two don't be afraid to switch
jobs for more pay you'll never get a
better you will never get a better raise
than by going to a new company oh yeah
and gaining experience and like also
knowing what else is in the industry and
also knowing what you like like how do
you know i wouldn't say just the same
job for
that much for very long as a young
person like three years tops tops yeah
i don't know because
i feel like
i only worked as a waitress until i was
like a youtuber so
both of them are not like
raise corporate jobs where you're like
asking for things but i i mean i do know
that as a as a host or an actor okay as
an actor um like i had a certain day
rate when i started and as over time
that started to go up as you build
your portfolio you you prove that you
can do the job and that you can do it
well that you're competent that you
understand how a production works that's
experience you can't buy you can't train
for it in schools so that's more
valuable to them than someone who
is new and and knows what to do but it
has never done it before right you know
and so your day rate goes up and it gets
to a point where like yeah you won't
settle for less and you i'm not afraid
to turn down jobs
that aren't going to bring to the table
is valuable yeah and i know what my
time's worth and you start to again
build more confidence in that and
understanding why it's valuable has been
the biggest key like with the marketing
thing understanding why companies want
to pay you to post a picture
is the like the value is like how you
leverage yourself because you are not
lying and you're not like
doing any manipulation tactic to get
more money which sometimes people feel
like they're doing if they're
negotiating but no you're actually
just knowing what you're worth and
sticking to it
i think it's super valuable mm-hmm
that's something yeah i don't know if i
don't know if i could just tell a young
person young me that and young me would
absorb it i think like you have to go
through it yeah you have the i have to
have the experience and also i think
confidence really is about trust and
that comes from trusting yourself so the
more that you can have conversations
that make you feel uncomfortable the
more you'll feel comfortable in them and
that's what builds confidence so the
next time you have a conversation about
something you don't know the answer to
you're like but i did this before yeah
and i'm okay yeah and i can stand up for
myself and a lot of people are afraid to
stand up for themselves because they
feel like they're gonna get in trouble
i do feel like i have to address the
opposite side of this which is um
entitlement i have
seen a lot of young people fresh out of
college that should be like you going
into an entry-level job or you're
interning or you're building that
experience that is going to ultimately
bring you the leverage to negotiate in
the future but they feel like entitled
to get the bigger pay right away
yeah like they deserve it no experience
but i am valuable i know my worth and i
earned it and it's like you didn't earn
it but you didn't yeah like the
experience really is like the whole meat
and potatoes of this game like you i
would rather work for free as an intern
for a year
get that experience and then use that to
negotiate a much higher pay at the next
job then try to demand higher pay when
you really haven't
earned that yet and you don't know what
you're doing you know when you demand
that high of pay you're saying i'm not
gonna [ __ ] up as much as that other
person and if you haven't done that job
before you're gonna [ __ ] up yeah and
it's gonna show and it's gonna look bad
and when you need referrals down the
line it's not gonna be good it's not
gonna happen
and it holds certain people back too
when they're so entitled they're like no
i don't want that job i'm too good for
that and they just remain yeah where
they are jobless yeah because that's not
good enough for me i'm like dude you're
broke yeah you need to work and they
just think they're too good for a job oh
i know actors like this so i i worked
with this actor well i worked with him
at a restaurant i worked with him on set
so he had been there for 10 years and he
would tell everyone like how he's such a
veteran at this restaurant and he was 30
years old and he was a sag actor and he
would tell everyone how he's in sag and
he's like he's part of the union a lot
of stuff he's an actor and he's an actor
and he's an actor and i was like so what
have you worked on lately and he's like
well i haven't worked on anything like
i don't know like eight years and i'm
like so
how do you like
still feel like an actor you know like
do you do do you go to class do you like
training education i did i did training
a long time ago i was like okay so do
you do student films like what do you do
and he's like no no they don't pay like
i'm a union actor like i just i need to
be paid a union wage and i'm like
okay so
does your agent send you out and like
he's like no i need more of a demo reel
first so it's like
okay so you won't work for free to build
a portfolio to then market yourself
because you're too good for it but
you're a veteran at this restaurant and
it's like i don't know how people get
locked into this entitled thinking yeah
and so i just want to protect you
against that too because you may be on
the path where you hear a lot of like
stand up for your self-worth and so you
you're going in there guns blazing but
also have the leverage first like build
the leverage and portfolio first to to
have that confidence and to know that
that's where your value is the
experience the experience versus the
entitlement yes yeah yeah that's the
experience exactly entitlements are
funny i always see stories on to talk
about people who are like this
influencer came into our restaurant and
try to get a free meal oh my god and
then i find out who the influencer is
it's like 5 000 followers huh oh god
that's just so embarrassing i would
never i don't even feel comfortable now
and
i've never done that in a restaurant
just like hey can i get this for free
hey like do you like know who i am yeah
yeah
one time we were in line at a las vegas
buffet and um the hostess recognized us
from jk news and she cut us in front of
the entire line and even that felt like
oh oh this is i feel like i don't i'm
not special like why are you doing this
i shouldn't have this that's very nice
but thank you see but you're the person
who deserves it because you're actually
grounded and you think logically and you
have the experience
thank you and also i think the
influencer space is so
still unreal to me because it wasn't
around like we when we started so
to think that like oh i've seen this
before and these people get these things
like right that wasn't a thing a thing
we all kind of came up together and
we're used to figuring it out begging
for
work and stuff so yeah it's really an
odd environment now
that's a great thing though yeah that
happens and you can still be humbled you
know that perspective i guess yeah if
you're sleeping on a terrible mattress
your sleep will be terrible it's that
simple that's why i recommend sleeping
on a purple mattress that's because only
purple mattresses have a gel flex grid
it's a super stretchy ultra squishy
material that adapts and flexes around
pressure points and doesn't retain heat
i sleep really really hot and usually
wake up sweating but not really anymore
with purple the gel flux grid is
amazingly supportive for your back and
legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips no matter how you sleep
personally i'm a side sleeper unlike
memory foam which remembers everything
the gel flex grid purple mattresses
bounce back as you move and shift you'll
never have that i'm stuck feeling that
people get from memory foam try a purple
mattress risk free with free shipping
and returns financing is available too i
also happen to get the purple pillow and
that's the one that i sleep on every
night as a side sleeper i have a really
hard time finding any pillow that hugs
my head and holds it at a right angle
someone's like too high somewhere too
low and the purple one actually fits
really well and i threw away all my
other pillows and i sleep with one
pillow now getting a great night's sleep
starts with having a great mattress get
a purple mattress go to purple.com big
mood 10 and use code big mood 10. for a
limited time you can get 10 off any
order of 200 or more that's purple.com
big mood 10 code big mood 10 for 10 off
any order of 200 or more purple.com
big mood 10 promo code big mood 10 terms
of play when it comes to looking good
stitch fix has you covered say goodbye
to endless browsing and say hello to
fresh picks curated for your taste and
size whether you need a date night dress
or cozy loungewear stitch fix can help
refresh your look all you do is you go
online you go to their website and you
start a profile and then you take a
little quiz and the quiz is so fun
because it's not words it's pictures and
you just click the picture that you like
better it'll be like do you like this
dress or this dress and then it's really
easy and then it curates your personal
style from the choices that you selected
and then it makes like a whole box for
you so you don't even have to pick out
what kind of things you want to wear it
already knows for you because guess what
it's smart it figured you out by your
choices because it's like got an ai in
there that's just it's like a little
stylist ai that knows everything
so there's no subscription required you
just keep what you like and you return
the rest it's the easy way to get items
that are just right for you from brands
you know and trust like madewell and
sanctuary oh my god i love madewell so
much it's time to get the looks that are
so you get started today by filling out
your freestyle quiz at stitchfix.com
big mood and take advantage of free
shipping and returns that's
stitchfix.com big mood to try stitch fix
stitchfix.com
big mood
can you get me the remote control for
the heater it's getting cold again oh
yeah let's turn it back on oh yeah thank
you oh yeah kitty go oh yeah kitty's
outside i see him with his little paws
he has to get used to that accident too
oh yeah oh yeah
i'm probably going to adopt it
i know i
you drink milk okay some cheese whiskey
and cheese
okay next sorry excuse us we're talking
all right why did you interrupt us
um
three don't stay in a relationship
sexual or platonic with someone if they
treat you badly life's too short you
don't have to be a dick about it but
excuse yourself and get away from them
i think we just talked about this with
stacey the boundaries
i hate that it's
so long to learn this right
i hate that it takes people so long to
learn it's not their fault really
because you weren't raised
with you know proper like there's from
uh families or people from divorced
families or whatever they don't know the
proper healthy relationship and it takes
so long to learn like i'm still learning
you know it also comes down to that
thing where it's like value right how do
we value ourselves
and we've all been in really shitty
relationships yeah right and
to get rid of toxic people friendships
and or relationships is really hard to
do because you kind of have to stand up
for yourself yeah and you can kind of be
uncomfortable and be like okay with
being alone steve was the first one that
pointed this out to me that like i'll
just overextend myself for anybody like
not even like just friends it's like oh
no this random person that needed my
help on the at this on the street corner
we're gonna go help him move right now
he's like why are we doing that who is
this person do we i'm like no but they
were really nice and they needed it and
he's like yeah we don't we don't we're
not doing that like you know it's very
nice of you you're helpful and i know
that you'll feel guilty if you don't
help but it's it's really not your job
we don't know them yeah yeah no i still
like have to learn i think like the
universe really taught me a lesson this
past december i was supposed to fly to
portland
and i
checked in my bag went through the gate
and there's this guy just sitting on the
side just sobbing his eyes out like his
stuff scattered on the floor his phone
was shattered and i was like
hey are you okay he goes i just want to
go home man i was like oh my god okay so
i'm like okay well what do you need help
with he's like my phone's dead and i
just don't know where to go and i
thought he was just kind of like not all
there yeah so i was like okay so i
brought him over to a plug here like
here's my phone charger
where's your gate he's look over there
and then so i went over there i'm like
and i explained they're like okay well
we need
him to come over with his id to get his
ticket printed out so i brought him over
like hey give him your id like i lost my
id i was like okay he said can i just
show you guys my credit cards and stuff
and my name's on there and he's still
sobbing and she's like here print an id
or printed a ticket and i was like
where'd you leave your id last he goes i
was over there at the bar and then we
went over to the bar and they're like
sorry we don't have it okay and then i
was like where's your ticket and he
ripped it in half what i was like what
the hell he's like what do i do i was
like okay so i asked the bartender for a
pen i literally wrote this guy's flight
info on his hand for him oh my god he
doesn't lose why didn't he rip it right
i don't know and then he i just sent him
on his way and then the people at the
bar were like
sweetheart you know he was drunk right i
was just that's what i was gonna say he
wasn't wasted and i was like what and
then they were like yeah he was here 20
minutes ago threw up on the bar lost his
id and that's why he's just like so all
over the place i thought he was he just
needed help yeah yeah
yeah and then
they were like no he was wasted and then
i didn't realize this but while helping
him i missed my flight oh [ __ ] that's oh
no oh my god and this was during the
holidays oh my god so i sat there from
like noon till 10 p.m
because i helped a guy that was just
drunk
and then
and then like dude like this was a whole
[ __ ] situation ah okay so
so
they told me so i was on standby like
three times and they told me there's no
more flights going out because it was
holidays and it was during that winter
time where
like they were snowing and then and
kovid got the omicron things everything
was getting canceled and then so they're
like there's some more flights i'm like
okay cool and then so i leave the
airport i walk out of the airport and i
hear the recent yeah she's like hey this
was last month this was literally
december okay like a week after
christmas and then so i i leave the
airport i walk out and i hear this woman
and just this old woman screaming in
vietnamese so i look over
and then the two employees that was with
her and her husband like there's this
elderly couple and the two employees
look over there like do you understand
vietnamese i'm like yes i do they're
like can you please come help and then
so this woman's crying
and she's her and her husband like a
thousand they were so cute
and they had like four giant boxes with
them in their luggage and i was like
what's going on and then she she
realizes oh my god someone speaks
vietnamese and she starts sobbing she's
like we've this is our first time in
america we went through a travel agency
and the travel agency kind of screwed us
they told us that all we needed for our
phones was no sim card you can just use
wi-fi to call everyone but we've been
trying to call but there's no [ __ ]
wi-fi anywhere so we can't call anyone
and then like we've been we can't talk
to anyone and they were just like that's
so sad yes so sad i mean america is the
worst for foreigners
they're so not like welcoming not
inviting like there's no other languages
on the signs no like when you go to
europe it's like everything there's
english listed and so you can navigate
learn english yeah oh my god so
she's like can you please help us i'm
like well i got [ __ ] to do now like yeah
i'll help you so first of all they were
in the wrong terminal they were in
domestics so you're just helping
everyone at the airport
missing your fight you're the santa's
helper of the airport there's a movie
thomas i live with the airport
that's what there's dirt
i've never heard of it yeah you were in
terminal yeah i lived at the airport at
this point because it was like seven
o'clock at night and i've been there
since noon and then so next thing you
know i'm like okay
i'm getting on the shuttle with them to
go to the international terminal i was
like here i'll take you yeah i'll take
you and then like she's like here's our
paperwork so i'm going through their
paperwork with like their coveted papers
and their passport and i have to explain
to them what's going on
and then we get to the terminal and then
i had to call like she needed a
wheelchair so i had one of the employees
like you know bring a wheelchair and
then i had to rent the [ __ ] mirror
i would like it was cool like they were
cute yeah i got to know them i had to
rent the [ __ ] carts for their luggage
because there's like giant boxes but
then like the the old man he's like so
like scattered all over the place he's
like i'm gonna go over here and smoke
i'm like no you have to come over here
like there's no time for that he's like
i'm gonna get up and get out of the
shuttle so i can go smoke i'm like no
you have to sit down because liability
issues you need a wheelchair and then
while we were pushing like we had an
employee to push us to the ticket
counter and i was pushing the other one
and then he's like oh there's another
vietnamese family stick with them i'm
like no stay here and this was testing
my vietnamese too and then so i had to
go to the counter and like show them
their covered papers and explain to them
that you only have one ticket right now
and then you'll get the other one that
layover because they don't have this
airline here so yeah wait over there
so when you go over there you have to
wait until they push you out of the
[ __ ] airplane and [ __ ] and it was
really cute they tried to offer me money
i'm like no no it's okay she started
crying and then and then she's like will
you stay with us until security i'm like
okay yeah so i'm like walking and then
right the security it was really cute
it's like sending off your grandparents
you're like the cutest thing
now it's like
8 30. you're like missing your second
flight no because there was no more
flight so now it's 8 30. i leave the
international terminal also my phone
goes off and says you are now on standby
for a 9 15 flight i was like what the
[ __ ] so
i have to go back to domestics
yeah but the ticket they showed me
didn't have a qr code for a ticket it
just says standby so i can't go through
security with that so i had to go to the
ticket counter but the ticket counters
holiday slammed so i just pushed my way
to the front i was like hey i have an
emergency she's like sorry i don't know
you have to go two doors down i'm going
to desk down like please for a love of
god she's like okay i can do it so she
goes
till things down two computers down and
print out a ticket i go through security
and then the standby list had three
extra seats left it was for three people
i was number four
no
no
gina did you ever get home
are you here what did you do in a past
life
and then so i like usually i uber home
but i didn't want to wait for an uber so
i called it my roommates i'm like can
you guys please just pick me up i don't
want to wait you're the drunk guy at the
end i just want to go home i just want
to go home
but this circles me down or circles me
back to
don't extend yourself so far and stretch
so far for people who don't deserve it
like the drunk guy yeah the universe was
also teaching me okay so the universe
was teaching me don't
do [ __ ] for people who are just who who
need help themselves and they won't help
themselves they're they're [ __ ] ups
because you're going to miss your flight
yeah at your own expense you know but
also don't forget to help the people
that really need it yeah you know that's
a great lesson
yeah and like one help is worth way more
than the other help exactly so then
myself was in portland for the last
[ __ ] month and i went back last or i
went last week to pick up my stuff from
my friend because he went to go grab my
luggage and he's been sitting in his
house for like a month so i got my stuff
you never made it there no i thought no
so that night i never made it oh but i
finally went last week oh okay yeah oh
[ __ ]
that's exhausting i mean that's
exhausting oh yeah i'm sweating just
thinking about all the walking and not
only that like not only did that
portland thing happen
i had literally was just in the airport
the day before because i flew home you
do live at the airport i know because i
flew home you are in jury right you are
tom hanks yeah i am tom hanks so because
i flew home from missouri from visiting
my dad for christmas the night before
and i came home and slept for like you
know 12 hours and went back to the
airport and
and i don't know that you should go back
to the airport at all
marketing things now here's the spring
man yeah oh that was wow but yeah like
cut off bad relationships when you need
to stop helping people that don't need
it and don't over explain what you're
sending but yeah you know but to help
the people that do need it help the ones
that need it but if you didn't miss your
plan you wouldn't have been able to help
those old people yeah that's true so
maybe it was like
it's all for the best yeah
i hope they're okay
it's nice everything happens for a
reason hindsight you know we learn
lessons along the way okay
number four some people don't want to
get married or just have their own goals
for a relationship marriage shouldn't be
the only option and that is okay stop
pressuring people to get married also
stop pressuring married people to have
kids also stop pressure
yeah stop pressuring grown-ups to not be
kids
it's not depression gets me down lane is
what it really is
people have their own goals at their own
times you know i think people just get
[ __ ] bored like they get bored of
their life so they're like let me just
mess with this person's life like i
don't feel something yeah like hey why
aren't you getting married why aren't
you miserable like me hey i'm not
getting married why aren't you getting
away yeah
hey
why are you you're married why you have
kids huh it's [ __ ] miserable why are
you having mccain
you're not eating hot cheetos in bed at
four in the afternoon like me talking to
you hey hey kid why don't you have a job
when are you have a job
four year old yeah yeah luca you [ __ ]
good
yeah i think people just need to [ __ ]
stop judging other people just live your
life yeah unless it's impeding on
someone's happiness
like just
let people live their own life yeah well
what does it matter to you if they get
married or if they have babies if they
have babies or if they don't get married
and then if you have a baby that's like
well you're gonna have another one my
friend just just had her baby like um
like she just stayed with us and it's
four months old it's so adorable and
she's like i'm so sick of people asking
me if i'm gonna have another one like
right i just had this one i just can't
get through this one she's like i
understand they want to know if it's
going to have a sibling but i haven't
[ __ ] decided i don't know this is all
new just let me enjoy this like
experience and see that should be the
okay answer to say yeah right but
instead we like sugarcoat it we're like
well i don't know when you should be
like i don't [ __ ] know yeah yeah i
just got to get through this baby first
yeah keep this one alive for another two
years maybe hey when are you gonna
propose okay so then they propose like
whoa how are you waiting like when's the
wedding i'm like [ __ ] chill okay and
like everyone take a beat timelines are
so different now too because people are
like oh you're 30 you don't you're not
married you don't have kids yeah people
have to do that before because they
would die at 32. yeah yeah yeah baby at
15. right like this is way different now
dude like like we're living in
antiquated structures we're gonna change
it a little let's adjust i don't have to
chase my dinner
yeah right
i think we're going to be okay i've got
to spear anything yeah i think our
generation kind of like was the catalyst
to
realizing that like hey we can normalize
taking our time a little
especially when like
it used to be like okay uh it's a
financial system like you know if you
don't get married and you're a woman you
can't get a job you literally can't
provide for yourself so your box look
you gotta get married like that now and
then like you could survive off of one
person's income and build a family and
do all that everyone needs to work so
now everybody gotta learn how to work
everybody gotta pick a job everybody
gotta get educated
and and so like it's a different it's a
different flow okay and i think that
like
older generations just live in the
timeline that they were trained in and i
don't blame them for that because how
would you know anything that's going to
be us guys it is going to be it already
is uh and it is already sometimes i'm
like blown away by this generation like
that's sometimes they say [ __ ] like
beggars can't be choosy and i'm like oh
my god who am i yeah
where did that come from
yes i've said that to my daughter many
times yeah i start repeating things my
mom has said to me and i'm like wait
this is my mom oh it's coming through me
right now we all become our parents too
whether you want to or not it's not up
to you
i'm just repeating prison yard [ __ ] from
my dad
want to work out gina's wearing her her
jeans under her butt like gina is this
are you okay yeah okay okay also it's 20
22 and women don't have to get married i
feel like more often times we ask women
like are you gonna are you guys gonna
get married but no one's asking the guy
yeah nobody's talking about that no
one's asking the guy if he's gonna have
a baby no no if he wants to get pregnant
yeah what his future plans are yeah also
like i don't get why everyone like i'm
so glad we have diversity and
perspective in this group because like
everyone seems to assume
that a woman should be really excited
can't look forward to anything else but
marriage and a baby and i don't i still
can't wrap my mind around it because
some of us
don't have baby fever like or you know
built up a wedding
i would i would always thought about
having kids like i really think that
we'd be good parents i like it i like
the idea of it i've never been baby
crazy yeah i've never been like i need
to have a baby i need to have one i'm
going to be like oh my god a baby like
oh i just once one day i'll have my one
day i'm gonna have it and but there are
a lot of women like that yeah and that's
great i love that like it's like find
your own path it's almost like we were
all given our own purposes and we're all
just kind of naturally drawn to what
those are and some people cannot
understand that other people might have
been given other purposes and other
things what is that driven too yeah wow
and so sometimes there's like moms that
love being moms and they're like when
are you gonna be a mom and it's like
okay you love being a mom
i don't know i don't know maybe i'll be
a mom maybe i want i'm just kind of like
figuring things out but i really like
doing this thing right here and i'm like
thriving and happy doing it why aren't
you building a youtube channel i don't
know like maybe you might be following
your passion yeah also too i don't know
this is like a segue into something a
different part of this but it's really
triggering for some women to be asked
when they want to have a baby because
some of them can't have cannabis yeah
and some of them have been trying for 10
years and are going through ivf or like
we don't know what someone else is going
through so we can't just put these
things on people and give them the
pressure of having to answer it in a way
that makes us feel okay yeah because
we're not answering in a way that makes
them feel good because they're not they
can't be honest and say actually i've
tried 15 times thank you for asking me
i've had three miscarriages and i feel
depressed yeah and i'm on moving i have
to medicate and now you've triggered
triggered me and now i can't have this
conversation anymore yeah instead they
go oh you know
and then they walk away yeah like how
sad
like the other way too where i'm like
people tell me like oh you don't want
kids do you know how many people want
kids out there that can't have it i'm
like all right whatever i'm at i don't
care yeah
your parents are like they're starving
children in india right now and like
mail it to them i don't know
my mom would say people in hell are
begging for water and i'm like i don't
know people in hell yeah
there's no relationship to them at all
what kind of mother earth is that why do
you know them yeah right am i in hell
yes yes yes you are oh okay yeah stop
[ __ ] judging people stay in your own
lane stay in your lane um
what's next okay as long as you're not
hurting yourself or anyone else be who
you really want to be all day long don't
conform to society to fit in with the
people who don't like who you are be at
a job friends family or even your
significant other nothing in this world
is worth sacrificing your real self this
kind of goes like on the other side of
stay in your own lane like this is the
person that's in their own lane like
don't feel guilty about being in that
lane authenticity and like being true to
yourself and knowing yourself that's
also a journey yeah a lot of people
don't know how to be true to themselves
and they don't even know who they are
you're not trained to
you're from a young age you're trained
to be an employee where for someone like
build some something for
someone else yeah you're not really
trained to like hey what do you want
what do you want to do yeah and like
except for when you're really little
people like what do you want to be when
you grow up you know
princess and doctor yes you can and then
you get to a certain age when they're
like well you can't be that yeah so pick
something real yeah and you're like oh i
thought all my life you said you told me
for 15 years yeah exactly i could be a
princess
what do you mean you know i think that
you can
absolutely do whatever your heart's
content is driven to do like i was like
i would like to order pizza in the
middle of night whenever i want and also
jump on the bed and also i want to stay
up late and watch movies and then now i
can so you know what being a doll is
[ __ ] rad it's actually awesome i love
it i love being an adult it's just the
people that are like well you can't do
that because you've got a dirt door
no you can't do that gym
i can do whatever i want to eat at gym
i don't know how they let me keep this
house but yeah
they dealt here adults are going to be
home soon
i love being an adult because it's like
now i have the money to buy a giant
[ __ ] barbie doll if i want yeah
absolutely
yeah i can be a giant barbie doll if i
want to i was saying on the break that i
feel like kevin from home alone where
like he goes
i'm eating drunk and watching rubbish
you better come out and stop me mm-hmm
but no one's gonna stop me
and you can
you can watch all the junk and eat all
the rubbish i love being there are
people who are like
you're too old to be playing video games
and reading comic books and [ __ ] all day
it's like no i'm not i could do whatever
the [ __ ] i want to do now and also i get
paid for it yeah or like there's people
coming to my streams and be like how
about you grow up and get a real job
like i guarantee you i get paid
you
more
what's a real job is it where you get
paid real american dollars right because
if so i think i have a real job yeah you
might have one of those yeah i can't
believe it's 2022 and people are still
saying that like back in 2010 people
were saying that on tuesday on youtube
and i was like oh yeah okay i can get
how you don't understand people are
making money on this platform but
really
okay i'll get comments like why would i
watch someone else play a game like i
don't know jim why are you watching
football yeah jim needs to [ __ ]
sit down people get really offended too
when you ignite anything inside of them
that makes them want to live any other
way like how dare you
that is what it is it's really their own
deep-seated like yeah and they didn't
get to do it so why should you yeah what
makes you so special do that and and it
means why did you eventually question
themselves like and they don't want to
have to confront the fact that they
might have had a better life had they
followed something that was inside them
i've been watching a lot of like videos
on
um
like that make you
rethink your perspective on the world
and kind of how we were trained to think
to live in society but society is really
just made up like people just made it up
right like if you think about like how
humans were put on the earth okay
somehow we don't need to discuss that
but like we're here and then like people
just made up rules and like it was just
people like you and me like we just made
them up in words and then other people
were like oh you got to follow them and
then so many followed it for so long
that that's why it's just accepted that
that's how you go but you don't like if
something's calling you and it's doesn't
it's not the way that all the fish are
swimming that's okay it's yeah it's okay
to explore that you could [ __ ] up you
could fail but like if something you're
going to regret not act at least trying
and you don't want to have regrets and
individuality is so sexy yeah it's so
sexy to be like wow they can think for
themselves you're a free thinker
wow weird barn doors well some of them
might be like you need to think like us
what are you doing but the other one
sounds cold
yeah
society is pretty cold yeah society is
pretty cold too they call it a culture
yeah i say that's true i say uh follow
your heart and you know what dr seuss
said something that was pretty brilliant
and it's like you got a brain in your
head and feed in your shoes and you can
steer yourself into whatever direction
you choose
direction i love that you know yeah i
sound like a home good sign now live
laugh love live laugh love live love
love choose it
you have a choice yeah
yeah i think um you know i read
somewhere that the the number one thing
people regret when they're at the end of
their life like on the deathbed is not
the things that they did do but all the
things they didn't yeah like very rarely
do people just regret things that they
actually did
um so yeah
don't have that i always think about
that
with regrets whenever i'm faced with a
big decision like should i go this way
or that way i'm like which one am i
gonna regret not doing right at the end
of the day and then that's the choice
you take me go that way do you want to
know the key to consistent good hair
days i like a moi uh yeah using
ingredients that benefit your hair like
your hair specifically function of
beauty makes hair care products that are
100 customizable they're made for your
personal hair like not just some generic
person's hair but yours specifically
where it's at now and where you want it
to go so you know you have hair goals
you don't want that frizz anymore you
don't want your hair to keep thinning
anymore you hate that it keeps falling
out you hate that it's not volumized
well guess what they have so many
combinations of different things like
they have 54 trillion possible
formulations can you even count the high
no you cannot not if you even lived five
lifetimes you couldn't count that high
so 54 trillion possible formulations
they're gonna find one that fits your
hair perfectly and every single one of
them is vegan and cruelty free they
never use sulfates or parabens gross
plus you can go completely silicone free
if you want to and here's how it works
you take a hair quiz so you're like yo i
want my my hair is wavy my hair is you
know straight and hey it's thick and
whatever you tell them what kind of hair
you have and then you select five hair
goals like lengthen volumize oil control
whatever you want and then you choose
your color and fragrance or you can go
dire fragrance free and then you get
your freshly filled formula delivered
straight to your door and prepare for
good hair days ahead and guess what for
me and this is just anecdotal but mine
seriously lasts at least six months and
i don't know if that's for everyone like
but mine has made it like eight months
or more before so it's just really
really really good value say goodbye to
generic haircare for good today go to
functionofbeauty.com
big mood to take your hair goals quiz
and you'll save 25 on your first order
go to functionofbeauty.com
big mood to let them know you heard
about it from our show and to get 25 off
your first order that's
functionalbeauty.com big mood to take
your hair quiz and save 25 off your
first order all right next one no one
told me that women can get unwanted
facial hair when we get older like
little chin whiskers and upper lip hair
nose hair that has to be trimmed stuff
like that in fact men are often
disgusted or grossed out to learn that
we get facial hair too but just about
every woman i've spoken to in my age
group my 40s gets these and we don't
tell girls or young women that this will
likely happen to them too i feel
personally attacked because i my chin
hairs like to poke out and they'll be at
the end of the day i'll look and i'll be
like oh man i wonder if anyone saw that
yeah
there's hair tom dick and harry just
want to come out to play sometimes with
people and i'm just like hi can you not
did any of you get like the long gray
one like a weird long
gray one like in my sideburns there's
like a it's always a random thing for
everybody like a random place on
everyone
one of my armed ones what is that no
idea it's thick and white yes it's weird
and it's always coming back
and it's like you weren't there
yesterday and now you're long in there
like where you get like long dark nipple
hairs yeah it happens to all of us yeah
that's weird they happen
and like little hairs happen sometimes
like especially when like i'm single i'm
like i'm gonna see how long i can grow
you
let me name you yeah nurture you like a
record
minor more like oh i didn't realize you
got that long yeah when did they last
shave you and they grow up like i want
to plug them in i'm going to plug you
they do yeah and it's always in the same
place that one chin here just comes back
you know why because they're the
youngest you know these hairs are like
we are sick of growing and then these
hairs are like we're new we're in the
world we're thriving we're gonna thrive
i have one on my shoulder that always
grows oh yeah you told me about that i
went on my low back that always grows
back and i'm like can you not like i
don't know because it was tugging at my
leggings one day not a sexy feeling
and i
went to the mirror and i'm like oh no
yeah
how many times has lacie looked at that
you can get a long back hair yeah it's
so strange super hot okay guys okay
you have a do you ever get long ass
hairs
no no i don't i get it waxed off i
rarely have like i really i really have
like body hair like my like hair doesn't
grow very much uh-huh so i don't get
like body hair but then my nipples are
like well i guess
we're gonna party over here yeah yeah
like you were gonna become tassels
we're gonna grow our own
the whole spirit is so strong
diy ourselves
um i don't get any arm hair like like
non-existent but leg hair was always
long when i was a child i was really
embarrassed because my parents won't let
me shave for like way later than my
peers uh and then like uh
so pubic hair like shaved it all i shave
it i don't like i haven't lasered it i
want to but i haven't um but i didn't
realize like i wasn't going far enough
back and so it there would be like long
like
or like that
or whatever
and i'm like well it's like my [ __ ]
has bangs
i'm into it is there anything you guys
can think of that like like other weird
like things like taboo body things i
realized that um
things take longer to heal
like i used to get a cut and then be
like scab the next day and then
and now it's like it takes [ __ ]
forever to get out of that scab phase
it's like here's still not skin the
regeneration process slows down the
older yeah yeah
and i guess i never really
thought about it because it just you get
so you take it for granted yes your skin
just like heals yourself but like as you
get older that takes longer to heal
bruises take longer to go absolutely
it's like like the hair follicles and
the regenerative process swift they just
swap places yeah now hair grows back
overnight and uh you just never heal
from things do you don't heal don't fall
and breathe internally either like
internally you're like just not healing
and i scar a lot easier now too yeah
the smallest scratches won't go away i
had a a band-aid burn um because i had a
very like tight band-aid on me oh
and that [ __ ] won't heal what it's like
i burnt myself from fire dancing before
that healed better than [ __ ] yeah it's
so dumb it's so dumb yeah i'll get a
pimple and then like i get scar like a
scar but like from a little tiny
blackhead it just like turns into a scar
the facial scarring is the worst [ __ ]
i don't can't get i can't understand it
can't keep up also i can't recover from
hangovers as quickly true what is that
about i used to be able to party gnarly
and wake up the next morning and then
do it again and now i'm like i'm gonna
need a week yeah talk to me in a week
yeah yeah i i don't drink much anymore
um so i think that also lowered my
tolerance absolutely but i i actually
went out and got shitfaced for the first
time in like a long time because my
friend was visiting my friend from high
school and it's vegas and she never she
just had a newborn so she never gets to
get away from the baby and so we had a
girls night and she can hold her liquor
down i cannot and i was trying to keep
up and we were at the crafts table like
freaking going at it and i was drunk
drunk to the point where the manager
like the floor manager kept pulling her
aside and asking her to check on me oh
no and i was getting pissed i was like
i'm not even drunk i don't even know he
why does he have a problem with me i'm
just trying to win i'm winning he's got
he's mad at me for winning i'm dealing
with it i was getting so like why i'm
not even drunk cut to like five minutes
later i'm hurling in the parking lot
just like
hurling my life away like i'm drunk i
didn't know it's even drama
i'm sorry for lying i'm sorry
the next morning i'm like why is it so
bright yeah i'm my sunglasses i'm like
indoors it's all loud why are people so
loud everything's loud
i remember being young going to raves
and doing drugs and the next day i'm
fine but now
not even getting drunk but just like
just having a night of casual drinks
here maybe a little bit buzz the next
day i'm like i'm [ __ ] depressed and i
just i don't want to leave my bed yeah
why won't this headache go away it's so
true that's the emotional impact yeah
like oh it's the calm down but it's like
it's it hurts
it hurts personally yeah it's like a
personal attack yeah you know what i
feel personally attacked by when i was
younger in my a teenager and in my early
20s i could eat a cheeseburger and it
would go to my nice juicy booty now i
even think about a cheeseburger and it
becomes a piece of cellulite on my lower
leg
under my knee even where i don't even
want to like wear in your pinky and not
even like
not see it or conceal it not that
there's anything wrong with cellulite we
all have it
um but yeah i'm mad about how my body
metabolizes yeah the [ __ ] food
yeah
i um have recently like lost weight and
i'm like why the [ __ ] why because i um
haven't i've been my whole life i'm like
okay i'm gonna go on workout program i'm
gonna eat healthy i'm gonna do all this
[ __ ] and i always like gain weight or
just maintain weight and i'm like i
don't get it i'm just [ __ ] getting
older whatever and then like i was
selling my house at the same time buying
my house and everything there was
holidays going on and i lost 10 pounds
and i'm like the [ __ ] is wrong with you
and i found out that like one stress
plays a big factor huge in how you're
metabolized and you don't stress when
you're young no
not as much maybe that's why i was
skinny or younger so i was broken i was
like how do i make it work they don't
tell you that the older you get your
hormones changed yeah and so that's what
happened tonight so like the nipple hair
that's the nipple hair and that was like
my body wanting the cheeseburger but
it's the hormones that don't allow your
body to
handle things that they use that's so
mean it's hormones you think that it
should get easier as it go it gets older
like just as like a just like as a
courtesy like a
creature you see like hey we're getting
older and like we've got to work really
hard when we were younger like can't you
just make it so we need less vitamins or
you know our hair grows even more
healthy or like is there something to
like look forward to can i not have the
ear hair that would be nice but instead
we got to learn all these like internal
life lessons that make us whole or as
humans and like do your blood work
so when i went to get my boobs redone
the doctor was looking at me okay so
yeah it should work and blah blah blah
and now that you have like looser skin
i'm like excuse you
he's like yeah well as you get older you
lose your skin like [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] 20
oh yeah yeah what do you mean looser
skin yeah
[ __ ] monster where show me where
point it
i remember i was getting a facial and
then um i i told the the esthetician i
was like i swear to god i saw like a
tiny fine line right here because i
frown a lot and i was like please just
tell me like i don't just please don't
lie to me because they have that big
magnifying glass
and she looks and she goes
yeah there seems to be a small one there
and i was like
i said tell me the truth i didn't
hold my hand
i just asked if you could supersize it
yeah right wrong house yeah
don't supersize this
okay well actually that's the next one
is uh no i knew i know this isn't taboo
but take care of your body little things
big things example wash your feet and be
careful picking up heavy objects things
that don't seem like a big deal become
one after you hit for 40. i can't
imagine how bad 50 feels
i can attest to this
take care of your teeth take care of
your teeth absolutely take care of your
teeth that's really really important and
also i had a really good friend who hurt
her back just by moving a chair because
it's
it was the angle and the way that she
did it body mechanics is really
important and working on your mobility
is longevity that just happened to steve
and what would take him like you know a
couple weeks to bounce back is like
taking months and i'm like why
can't we have sex tonight oh because
you're back at your back hurts from the
patio furniture from four months ago
oh my god we recover differently yeah we
have covered so differently everything's
different like our muscle tone is
different our our hormones like we were
saying i had a girlfriend who is in the
wellness world as well and she was like
you want to know the number one thing to
increase longevity get out of chairs and
up from things without using your hands
and your arms oh
that thing alone every time you get up
from sitting down just try to get up
using
no hands and no arms because it forces
you to engage your core and your core is
actually from like here to your shoulder
that's like 36 months
it's not just your core i don't have a
core yeah i have zero just working and
you're getting out of that i do your
workout program and you're like do a
sit-up or like do a push-up on your
knees i'm like no there's nothing there
i can do squats and that's it like i
only have legs and then
nothing she's great at a squat let me
tell you i can't if you can just do that
even get out of the get off the couch
without using your hands use your core
like that increases longevity
but can you imagine someone telling you
that at 20 you're like shut up oldie
yeah fine yeah i'm good seriously
you have to use your hand to get out of
the chair
i like squat it down the other day and
my knees cracked i was like [ __ ] you
shut the [ __ ] up it's always the knees
yeah i just walked up a stair and it did
that like excuse you what dare you did i
say when you get older call me old would
you say
we used to dance for hours okay calm
down
being bullied it's always the knees and
the low back and the shoulders now i
sound real old shoulders yeah for me my
my neck my back my [ __ ] and my cracking
most importantly that i always tell
people like take care of your [ __ ]
teeth dude because we don't get new
teeth we're not sharks and you know what
else i had always thought like okay
we're not sure
you can't
um okay when i get like when they get
all mangled i'll just get veneers yeah
then i was reading something and i don't
know if it's true or not because i just
like soak up things that i hear and then
i absorb them sack i've talked about
this before so i don't know but i've
heard that uh like there's a part of
like memory that's stored in your teeth
like when you chip a tooth or your your
tooth anatomy changes it [ __ ] with your
memory like it [ __ ] with i don't know
if it's the way you store memories or
like memories that you already have that
are now gone or it's like you're a
short-term long-term or whatever but
like people start having memory issues
when their teeth start going bad or like
when they lose a tooth or they chip a
tooth or they had to get like a tooth
shaved or something oh man and i'm like
oh [ __ ] because when you get veneers
they like shave it to like put them in
yeah i'm like well that [ __ ] with it no
one should ever get those done by the
way yeah there's two different kinds of
veneers the ones where like influencers
are going to [ __ ] whatever brazil to
get it all the sharks
shave down and then pop in those
and first of all they look [ __ ]
terrible yeah it looks like a mouthful
of chiclet yeah like it's even worse
nobody like nobody realistically has
square perfect porcelain white toilet
bowl white no um so there's that's one
way and it's there's also what i did
where i i got composite veneers because
i wanted things
and i wanted to even out like i had here
yeah yeah where it's they keep your
teeth they just build they it's like
they it's like putting play-doh on it
and then oh yeah they're gonna feel like
yeah the uv light cures it and then it
matches your teeth too so you don't have
to [ __ ] up your real teeth you're just
building it's like acrylic nails for
your teeth yeah those are great thank
you i love imperfections
though is if you grind your teeth i
grind my teeth it's the same you gotta
get a mouth guard or something but then
people are like i heard so many mixed
things because they're like don't get a
mouth guard cause it [ __ ] with your jaw
and i'm like what the [ __ ] what do i do
you can't get the ones you can't get the
ones that people just buy and mold at
home you get it actually done by
professionals yeah like experts
otherwise you'll [ __ ] up your jaw but
you know about did i tell you about the
bonding when nick jonas threw a
pineapple on my face
it's a weird [ __ ] sentence but go
ahead nikki i wasn't i was in vietnam
it was 2018. i was in um
and i was it was for like a brand thing
and um there was a giant water slide
that they built
and the celebrity host was nick jonas
and the game was you had to go down this
giant water slide get flung into the air
as he's throwing a pineapple at you you
try to catch it oh [ __ ] we couldn't find
anything else to throw no it was a fake
pineapple but it felt real oh god it was
like um like a
not plastic but like rubber pineapple
yeah
yeah and so uh so i'm in the air i'm in
a i'm in nam going down a water slide
nick jonas
she's airborne and dumb okay i'm
airborne
and then jonas who actually knows how to
throw really well because he was like he
plays baseball or something um he throws
a pineapple it wasn't the actual
pineapple but as i was catching it i my
teeth clamped because like you were
smiling yeah and then i landed in the
water and i was like part of my tooth's
missing
i was like oh no i was like my
i'm so disoriented i'm like in the water
the juice is missing that sounds she
drunk and it was an alcohol brand too
and we weren't allowed to drink on it
because they didn't want liability and
they were like stop saying that and they
stop saying your tooth is oh no but i
can't feel it i don't know what i'm
going to do
and i get out i'm like i think my tooth
is broken and i couldn't shut up about
it
and then
i needed to see a mirror but there was
no mirror because we're in the [ __ ]
middle of a desert
and then i finally
came to a mirror and like so it wasn't
my whole tooth but it the front like so
the front portion of it like got carved
out like this
and i and i even had a layer a piece of
it in my hand
and um and so it was yeah it was just a
layer but they had to do that bonding
thing where they went over it with a
camera
mess with your teeth you lose your
memory so
i feel like that sounds like a wives
tale for like why they call it wisdom
teeth oh you think
cool
yeah i had never heard of it before too
and i don't know what my source was it
just
went in my brain by someone now i've
absorbed it and it's part of mine here
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me
anything that scares the [ __ ] out of me
i go okay noted gonna keep that one
must be real
all right well guys that's a lot for you
to absorb your little young minds that
haven't even developed fully in your
frontal cortex and all that [ __ ] but
hopefully you absorb some of it and
hopefully some of it was true i don't
know fact check me i don't care oh
really quick you know people are like
women should be married by blah blah
blah and then i learned that men's
frontal cortex or they don't mature
until 30 something why you telling me
these women had to marry these men
before they were even mature let's not
marry them until they're mature all
right that's why they always kill their
husbands and they force
like you have to become a caretaker they
want a mama they need they left their
mama they need a new mom because their
frontal cortex is not fully developed
ladies hold it down write it down hold
off hold off marry the woman's
weight or marry older okay did you get
that got it got it okay
well leave a comment let us know if
there's anything that you've learned in
your old age or if you're a youth and
you think all this is [ __ ] and why
you don't agree i don't really know
because they're the old ones right also
the thing they don't tell you about
being older is you don't care
yeah i don't care it's awesome but i do
i love you and uh follow our guest she's
got a lot of amazing things going on if
you want to kind of reverse aging
biologically like with physically you
can do that by working out and she has a
phenomenal workout class my therapist
actually told me that she said you could
refer to biological age by like
really taking care of your body and i
was like holy [ __ ] really absolutely
that's true um we talked about that in
another episode i mean i'm gonna be 98
next month so look at this
see that amazing all right follow her
everywhere leave us a comment we love
you and we'll see you next time
[Music]
you